okay so we're gonna go over the
lifecycle of moss and actually before we
get into the specifics of moss I want to
take a moment and review the general
life cycle that plants go through and so
let's take a moment to review that first
so here's a diagram that we saw the
other day in class and it's the pattern
of plant reproduction plant life cycles
called alternation of generations and
what we mean by this is plans will
alternate between a haploid and a
diploid stage in their life well let's
start with a stage I hope we all
recognize the zygote so as I go if you
recall is created when a sperm cell and
an egg cell fuse together so a zygote
because it's half sperm and half egg
half-and-half adds up to a whole so a
zygote is a diploid cell a complete set
of chromosomes that belong to that
particular species so a zygote is the
first original diploid cell so a zygote
marks the beginning of the diploid stage
in the life and that's why it's the B at
the beginning of this peach colored area
the peach color is the diploid stage
well follow the cycle in the picture
the zygote will divide by the process
known as mitosis it might take years and
years and years and in some plants it
might even take decades but eventually
the zygote will divide eventually enough
times over years and years to create an
adult sporophyte and not every plant by
the way takes years and decades I mean
some plants only live for one year so in
some plans this process happens in at a
fairly rapid pace but other plants that
live a long time like redwood trees and
sequoia trees this may take years for
them to reach their adult sporophyte
stage so after a plant has reached its
adult sporophyte stage follow the arrows
a portion of the sporophyte report will
perform meiosis and anytime meiosis is
performed I hope you know you are
starting with a diploid cell and ending
haploid so notice how the picture
changed from peach which is the diploid
color to blue which is the haploid color
because meiosis is performed so meiosis
creates haploid spores Wow well those
spores are then released into the air
and carried by wind may be carried by
rain and eventually those spores are
gonna land and if you see follow the
picture the spores will grow into what
is called a gametophyte
so when the spores land the spores are
haploid and they grow into the haploid
organism called the gametophyte and some
gametophyte are male some gametophyte s'
are female and in the word gametophyte I
hope you can see the prefix for gamete
so the gametophyte s' are gonna make
gametes if I were to ask you what will
the male gametophyte create I hope you
know the male gametophyte creates the
male gamete called sperm if I were to
ask you what will the female gametophyte
create I hope you know that the female
gametophyte is the egg so the female
gametophyte creates the female gamete
I think I may have said that wrong the
female gametophyte creates the female
gamete the female gamete is the egg that
sounds better in my head
hopefully I said it right the first time
and so once the egg and sperm have been
created all it takes is the sperm to
swim to the egg for fertilization to
take place
so the sperm will swim to the egg so
plants actually have swimming sperm not
all plans but the plans we're gonna
focus on today moss they definitely have
swimming sperm to have a little flagella
that propels them through the watery
environment where they live so some some
plants will have swimming sperm that
will swim to the egg fertilize the egg
and create a zygote and again that will
restart that will restart the diploid
stage in the life of a plant so when the
zygote has been recreated our cycle
repeats and so now we're just repeating
ourselves and in this alternation of
generations this is the general pattern
of plants now we're gonna focus our
attention specifically on Moss today so
why don't we go ahead and look at the
category of plants that Moss are in
eventually we're going to learn about
three groups of plants we're gonna start
only by looking at Group one today these
group Group one are the scientific word
for for seedless and nonvascular plants
are called bryophytes I've highlighted
bryophytes in the cladogram in the
animation so a bryophyte is a seedless
plant that is also not vascular these
are the most primitive of plants if you
look at the cladogram look at the bottom
the green algae ancestor follow the line
up the first branch leads to a plant
called Horn words the second branch to a
plant called liver words the third
branch to a plant called mosses these
are are called bryophytes these are
seedless plants and not vascular
and so what we know about them is some
basic traits such as they live in moist
environments even though they live on
land the land where they live is fairly
moist and it makes sense because in
order to reproduce their sperm needs to
swim through water so they have to live
near moisture
and here's an example of a liverwort if
you've never seen pictures of liver
words before here they are they're
fairly small to the ground because
they're again they're non vascular
here's some picture a picture of some
horn words again they're very small to
the ground no more than an interest or
inch or two or so tall very small to the
ground nonvascular and here's a picture
of something we've all seen I'm sure
we've all seen moss growing on a rock or
in between cracks on the sidewalk again
Moss is a very small it's a seedless
plant and because it's small its non
vascular so again just the picture
showing the three different types of
seedless nonvascular plants again the
scientific classification is called
bryophytes so these are examples of Frye
ophites
so let's focus our attention on mosses
we're not gonna say too much about horn
words or liver words let's just focus on
mosses we're all familiar with mosses
we've all seen them grown here's a
common picture of what moss looks like
it looks like just green carpeting on
the on the ground of the forest and keep
in mind we've mentioned this a few times
already because they're non vascular
they're gonna grow low to the ground now
they still need water they still need
nutrients so they have to have a way to
get water they have to have a way to get
nutrients transport it around to every
cell and it's simply diffusion that does
this other plants have a vascular system
like big trees sequoia trees they have a
vascular system their vascular system
carries water and nutrients all around
the tree
well mosses don't have a vascular system
but they still need to carry a water and
glucose and other nutrients to all
around their their their cells and they
use simply diffusion to do that
here's a picture of the leaf of a moss
and I hesitate to use the word leaf
because according to classification we
don't even consider these to be real
leaves so we you know the notes say that
they lack true leaves so I'm not a
hundred percent sure as to what makes a
leaf a true leaf so if you can find that
out maybe posted in the comment box that
would be great but I think the main
reason why we don't consider them to be
true leaves is because they again they
don't have a vascular system true leaves
have veins that branch off different
directions if you pluck a leaf off of a
tree look at the leaf you'll see veins
on it and these don't so I think that's
the reason why we don't consider them
true leaves but you can see they're real
thin only one cell thick and size so
then you can see light passes through
them
they have an anchoring system called
rhizoids so here's a diagram of a
drawing of moss and if we look beneath
the dirt if we look beneath the dirt we
can see that in the diagram the these
route this route like system called
rhizoids holds them and anchors them
into the soil and this is something we
mentioned during the ecology unit
earlier in the school year we mentioned
that moss and lichen are good examples
of pioneer species because they are
often the first to inhabit new
ecosystems and over time the ecosystem
accumulates more biomass the ecosystem
goes through a series of changes known
as secession but if you recall this is
more for review purposes lichen and moss
this presentation is about mosses so
mosses are one of the the pioneer
species that we talked about earlier in
the school year
so let's go into the lifecycle of a moss
here we have a just a real pretty
picture of a forest floor covered with
moss and so whenever you see moss what
you're looking at is the gametophyte
stage
remember plants alternate between
gametophyte and sporophyte back to
gametophyte back to sporophyte back to
the me to fight and so what you're
seeing
whenever you see moss you're almost
always gonna be seeing the gametophyte
stage it's the dominant stage they spend
the majority of their cycle in the
gametophyte stage just a reminder this
is the haploid stage but anytime you
come across moss you're probably looking
at the gametophyte stage well let's go
through their cycle now so before
actually I forgot about this bullet of
information right here if you just kind
of use your imagination it kind of looks
like a layer of green shag carpeting and
when I saw this picture I immediately
thought of my grandparents home Oh house
when I was growing up so this isn't an
actual picture but this is a picture of
that reminded me of what my grandparents
carpeting used to look like my
grandparents were kind of stuck in the
1960s 1970s so they were a few decades
behind in their in their furnishings and
how they styled their house and so I
just remembered they had real thick
green shag carpeting and III think a
moss whenever I see stuff like this but
let's actually go on to their lifecycle
lifecycle now
so here we have just a drawing of a male
gametophyte again if you come across
moss growing in between the cracks of
the sidewalk or growing on a rock if you
come across moss you're looking at its
gametophyte stage now with the naked eye
you're not gonna be able to tell is that
the male gametophyte or is that the
female give me the fight you really
can't tell it's too small with the naked
eye but if we could zoom in and take a
closer look we would see that at the
very tip of the male gametophyte let's
take a look at zoom in and take a look
right now here we are if we were to zoom
in to the very tip of the gametophyte
with a high-power microscope you can see
in this picture we're at 400 times
magnification at the very tip there are
little housing structures called
antheridia antheridia is the plural and
thrid ium is singular and inside of
every antheridium are hundreds and
hundreds of sperm cells now again you
can't see this with the naked eye but
they're there if you could zoom in with
a high-powered microscope well what
about the female gametophyte again you
might have to Moss plants growing
side-by-side you can't with the naked
eye you're not gonna be able to tell the
one on the left is male the one on the
right is female you're not gonna be able
to tell with the naked eye but if you
were to zoom in to the tip of the female
one just like we did with the male one
let's zoom in right now
here we are if we zoom in to the tip of
the female gametophyte with a
high-powered microscope we could see
that there's a little housing structure
called the archegonium and inside of
every archegonium creates an egg an egg
created created that will eventually
fuse with the sperm cell to create a
zygote but we're not ready for that yet
so let's just focus on the fact that
gametophyte scum in male versions
communica me to fight scum in female
versions and so the problem is we have
sperm on the plant on the moss to the
left wanting to get to the female on the
right well in order to do that there has
to be something for the sperm from the
male to swim through so here we go
the sperm cells in order to fertilize
the egg have to be able to swim from the
male gametophyte on the left to the
female gametophyte on the right but
these things live on land so how do they
swim easy rain water here we go we're
gonna make it rain
it's raining and now that there is a
layer of water on the ground in a moment
you're gonna see sperm cells swim from
the gametophyte on the left to the
gametophyte on the right in this
animation I only made three sperm cells
in reality we're talking hundreds if not
thousands so here we go watch the three
sperm cells swim from the left to the
right here we go
and there they are notice how a couple
of the sperm cells went off in the wrong
direction but one of them one of them
fertilized the egg that was inside of
the archegonium once that happened they
created a zygote a diploid zygote if you
recall the diploid stage is called the
sporophyte stage so the zygote marks the
beginning of the diploid stage known as
the sporophyte so the sporophyte stage
begins when the zygote is created and
over time that zygote will divide by
mitosis one cell becomes 2 to become 4 4
become 8 and are eventually a stalk
begins to grow here we go
a stock begins to grow out of the zygote
and notice at the tip of the stock
there's a little bulb of a round little
structure at the tip this is called a
capsule and inside of that capsule are
spores being created by the process of
meiosis so if you notice though the
sporophyte stage is actually attached to
the green female gametophyte stage so
the sporophyte stage actually gets its
nutrition from the gametophyte stage so
you're not gonna find the sporophyte
stage growing separately on the ground
the sporophyte stage is literally
growing on top growing out of the female
gametophyte stage so those fours that
are gonna be created inside the capsule
by meiosis eventually those spores are
going to be released into the wind so
those spores are eventually going to be
released into the wind and they will
land on the ground and grow into new
gametophyte so here we are they're gonna
blow away in the wind right now there
they go they're blowing away and notice
how to of those black dots representing
spores
notice how two of those spores landed on
the ground if you're still copying the
notes you might want to hit the pause
button because in a moment all the words
are gonna do
but here we go those two black dots are
spores they landed on the ground and
what's gonna happen now that those
spores landed on the ground those fours
are gonna grow into new gametophyte once
four might grow into a male gametophyte
the other spore might grow into the
female gametophyte again with the naked
eye can you tell the difference between
the two not really but with the
microscope you can zoom in to the tip of
the male gametophyte and if you zoomed
into the tip of the male
and Lydia which produces sperm
for the female gametophyte
to the female gametophyte you would see
the archegonium with an egg inside and
so now that they've created the sperm in
the egg the sperm needs to swim to the
egg so therefore it's gonna have to rain
again here comes the rain now that water
is on the ground we're gonna have sperm
cells swimming from the male to the
female gametophyte this time I only drew
one sperm cell I didn't draw more than
one but here it goes the sperm cell is
swimming and eventually fertilizes the
egg to make a zygote
the zygote marks the beginning of the
diploid stage in the life of a plant in
this case the life of a Maus
so eventually the water will evaporate
and from that zygote just like we saw
earlier from that zygote a new
sporophyte will grow with a stalk with
the capsule and remember what's being
created inside of that capsule our
spores that's why it's called this for a
fight
the sporophytes creates spores and
eventually the spores will be released
into the air the spores are released
into the air and the cycle repeats again
so all we're seeing here is how plants
alternate between diploid and haploid
diploid and haploid the sporophyte
remember is the diploid stage the
gametophyte is the haploid stage
here's a diagram from the textbook look
in the back of the book I believe this
is appendix B in the back of your book
it's probably the words might be a
little too small to read in this video
but if you go to Appendix B in the back
of your book it'll be helpful for you
if you don't have your book well
hopefully the video notes that we just
went through were helpful if not come
and talk to me and I'd be happy to
clarify so here's a good practice for
you here's six steps of the moss life
cycle jumbled up out of order so if you
want to try this hit the pause button
spend some time and try to put these six
steps in order from start to finish I
gave you step number one a spore lands
on the ground
well now what so try to figure out these
pause the video if you want more time
and here is again the quiz that I like
to put at the end of many of our notes a
Kobe quiz just practice quiz questions
you can find all of these somewhere in
the PowerPoint presentation so again if
you want to work on these pause the
video take some time and go back through
the notes and try to find the answers to
these questions these make good practice
before we eventually have a test or a
quiz if you need any help understanding
moss and plant reproduction come on into
my classroom and I'd be happy to spend
some time with you